actress senegal martin green is
returning to her role as michael burnham
in the fourth season of the paramount
plus series star trek discovery burnham
is making history as the first black
female captain in the franchise's
55-year run in a preview clip from
thursday's episode her role as captain
begins with a huge challenge
discovery
today we seek to understand a threat
like none our galaxy has faced before
we know the cost of its destructive
power all too well
we lost colleagues
friends
and quajon
countless lives
histories futures
we won't let their deaths be in vain
and we are going to make damn sure
nothing like this happens again
not on our watch
not on our watch
black alert
seniqua martin greene joins us now
good morning good morning no but i love
like
the universal sound of a proof
it's so true i appreciate you thank you
for having me because sanequa that scene
i mean you are a starfleet captain
you are a starfleet captain and you made
history
in becoming a starfleet captain right
talk to me about that
oh it's hard to talk about without
crying really
yeah it it it is it is and and really
because i've been growing so much here
lately um
we were talking about this just just a
moment ago i i lost my parents in april
uh one day of each other and this year
of this year
wow and thank you so sorry um and and so
there's been a lot of
maturation happening in in my heart as a
result of it and then this is happening
at the same time and i found it a little
difficult to celebrate there for a
little bit um because making history in
this way um obviously it's something
that i thought i would do while they
were here
and i know they are here and i know that
they're proud and everything but it just
it just has so many layers and it's it's
quite surreal
but i've also realized that it's not um
it's not what i thought it was i was i
was quite self-oriented about it for a
long time
because before i was the captain i was
still the first black female to lead a
trek show i remember and i thought well
this is all i i got to do this i got to
do this right i got to say everything
right i got to be perfect i got it
that's the only way i'm going to do it
justice that's the only way i'm going to
pay homage to the people that have come
before me like you
and that's the only way and what i
didn't realize is that that was making
it all about me when it's all up to you
it's all about you
and so i'm coming out of that as well
which is um it's profound and i'm i'm
grateful i'm grateful yeah the burden of
history one of the most storied
franchises
in the world the fans
but also losing your family and then
also having a young daughter that's
right you have a son but you also had a
daughter and then the pandemic yes and
then everything that happened around the
police brutality and right
all of that going into going into your
role as
burnham at this moment and i can see it
i can see it now that the first episode
has premiered i didn't watch it ahead of
time i waited um so i could see it with
the world
and i can see all of that i didn't
realize that it was visible at the time
yeah yeah you know what i'm saying but i
i can see it i i was freshly postpartum
um you know a bigger burnum than we're
used to seeing
which which is beautiful um but i was
carrying not just physical weight but
but so much weight emotional weight
spiritual weight uh at the same time and
i can't see it i can see i think i'm
still stunned by the death of your
parents i had no idea i'm so so sorry to
hear that thank you um
but i look at your character and it
there seems to be a dynamic between you
and the president
she seems to be coming for you as the
kids of today say so it's going to be
interesting to see the dynamic between
the two of you but i love the the
tagline that you have when i when she
came into the green arm like let's fly
yeah i love that tagline for you and you
said it's very in
very emblematic of who she is that's
right it very much is well because
burnham
it's interesting that you uh talk about
that moment with president rillick in
burnham because
i'm not sure i like president
i like you
natural tension between that's right
that's right
our fleet officer it's normal sorry
because there's there's this idea of um
you know burnham is very uh obviously
very self-sufficient and and and
tenacious and and driven and
effective as well uh but then there's
also still so much to learn and we've
been able to see this woman grow and
change and fall forward and it's a
luxury that's provided in this sort of
utopian future with this black woman
being able to make mistakes and being
able to fall forward and still burst
past that ceiling so the the president
is is challenging her well i'm rooting
for you i'm a little creeped out by the
faces
vlad is a trekkie for for real for real
i'm sure he knows that she knows that
hey
please no we're cheering you on love
always so neuqua martin green we thank
you thank you thank you you can watch
new episodes of star trek discovery
every thursday on viacom's cbs streaming
service it's called paramount plus